pigs at the trough how corporate greed
and political corruption are undermining
America is arianna huffington's
examination of the relationship between
corporate leaders and politicians she
argues the corporate responsibility Act
does not do enough to stop corporate
wrongdoing this is just under an hour
thank you very much for this great
introduction thank you all for being
here and thank you for that great piece
that you did on lobbying because that's
central to this book and what we're
talking about well first of all CEOs
have undergone an amazing transformation
in the last year they've gone from being
America's royalty to being America's
Most Wanted and it really if you think
of it is about as amazing a
transformation as what MTV managed to do
with Ozzy Osbourne in returning him from
a satanic rocker to America's cuddliest
dad and what makes his transformation
even more amazing is that despite it
very little has really changed and when
the president in the State of the Union
speech had the hutzpah like any good
Texas boy to to say that we've kind of
basically passed tough reforms to handle
corporate responsibility and it was
really an amazing statement given that
not only was the sarbanes-oxley bill
that he referred to passed you know over
the objections really of most Republican
senators it was a bill that the
President had never supported that he
signed into law only because of the
public outcry after worldcom but also
because since then as the New York Times
pronounced in a front-page story last
week Harvey Pete is amazingly still at
the SEC even though he resigned three
months ago and he is regularly daily
apparently undermining altogether
killing the reforms that the president
was celebrating at the State of the
Union
and that in a nutshell is what's
happening with corporate reform while
the public was paying attention this
bill was signed with great fanfare as
soon as the public moved on to other
issues like Iraq and the burning issue
for the JLo and Ben Affleck are going to
stay together the administration and
Congress have really proceeded to
surrender once again to the lobbies who
really hold the major power in
Washington and one of my favorite bars
before have you
one of my favorite sidebars in the book
is on page 192 and it's called
all in the family and it's about the
incredible close ties between Washington
lobbyists in Washington elected
officials so when I say close ties I
mean really close I mean like sleeping
together or being offspring
Linda Dashiell for example married to
Tom Daschle chief lobbyist for American
Airlines and is there any surprise that
the Democratic leadership did not fight
the massive multi-billion dollar bailout
of the airline industry immediately
after September 11th indeed passed it
incredibly quickly without any
provisions for workers that was the
stunning thing a 15 billion dollar
bailout package that did not include
include any protections for workers and
that in fact was followed by massive
layoffs and bankruptcies so when the
president in the State of the Union
stands up and celebrates the fact that
he's going to give 450 million dollars
to mentor children of prisoners and
other children
the question is 450 million for this
huge social problem compared to 15
billion dollars for a bailout of an
industry that had been looking for this
bailout long before September 11th and
that like many other interests is used
September 11 to get what they wanted and
just as an aside mentoring the children
of prisoners many of whom are there
because of the most misguided drug laws
in this country
that have 500,000 nonviolent drug
offenders in jail I know that's an aside
but you know public policy has massive
implications and of course part of my
own transformation from being a moderate
Republican I was always modeled on the
social issues to being a populist
progressive because I haven't become a
Democrat and I haven't become somebody
on the traditional left because I think
a lot of this left-right distinctions
are so obsolete but one of my one of the
things that most pushed me in that
direction was the fact that really we
cannot deal with this massive social
problems through the private sector
alone or even through the private sector
predominantly a because we need the raw
power of government appropriations and B
because we need the government watchdog
role and that's really what we've lost
we've lost this oversight capacity that
government institutions have over the
free market and I want to start by
making clear that although we talk about
corporate scandals and although I talk
about pigs at the trough after heart
these scandals are political scandals
greed has always existed you know we're
not going to end greed and corporate
scandals have always existed what makes
the the ones we we are going through
right now because this morning in the
papers who had Global Crossing again
that they the degree to which senior
execs defrauded their investors turns
out to be even more blatant than we
thought
and so the fact that all these scandals
went on throughout the nineties are not
continuing now and we're allowing them
to continue is because of the fact that
so much of government so much of public
policy is now paid for by lobbies in the
interest of corporate America and you
know that sounds simple but it's so
fundamentally true that I have so many
dozens of examples here but let me just
give you two the homeland security bill
that was passed
at the last Congress included two
provisions who should have taken us to
the streets one of them was the Eli
Lilly provision that gave Eli Lilly and
a multi-billion dollar giveaway
protection from lawsuits from parents
claiming that the children became
autistic because of a mercury additive
in an Eli Lilly vaccine now this a had
absolutely nothing to do with homeland
security right and B was introduced into
the bill in the 11th hour without
anybody taking authorship and you know
this is a town where everybody's
clamoring to take credit for everything
but not for the Eli Lilly provision and
the other provision which is equally
outrageous was to reverse the ban on
corporations that had moved to tax
havens receiving government contracts I
want to see how our rafflesia because
nobody asks the price than many
questions but Ari Fleischer on the
president's behalf could justify at the
time of war and supposedly shared
sacrifice having American corporations
not paying taxes and yet getting
taxpayer money in the form of government
contracts I mean this is really public
policy made in an insane asylum
it cannot be justified in any way nor
can this administration really justify
the fact that Jon Snow has been
confirmed as Treasury secretary John
snow presided over a company that in 3
out of the last four years paid no taxes
even though it made close to a billion
dollars in profits and now he's going to
be in charge of the IRS and so at the
time when all of us are going to be
finding our tax returns and paying taxes
whether we like it or not we must
remember that in the last three or four
years if we paid $1 in taxes we paid
more than Jon Snow's company
and that was through a van Rijn and then
you have people who say well it was
legal I'm not saying it was legal the
outrage is that all that stuff is legal
and it is legal for a reason the outrage
is that the so-called generally
acceptable accounting principles are
over a hundred thousand long so just
about everything is legal
you know Goldman Sachs for example one
of my favorite examples of these
absurdities created this little
financial instrument in the booming 90s
called MIPS monthly income preferred
shares which was equity in the balance
sheet of the company any company and
debt when you prepared your IRS tax
returns wouldn't you like to have
something like that when you do your own
private tax returns so why should
American corporations operate under a
different set of laws and rules than
ordinary Americans this is a kind of
Upstairs Downstairs America we have
created which basically is not
sustainable in the long term because it
involves a bloodless coup of our
democracy and nothing less is at stake
that's why this is ultimately a question
of democratic politics and not just a
question of economics and how we're on
our corporate or corporate citizens and
I think it's laughable when you watch
those CNBC shows where they're trying to
tell you that you should get back in the
market and they are basically debating
among themselves as to what shares to
buy and then they're amazed that the
public isn't listening why should the
public listen why should the public
regain faith in the market and in the
economy without any fundamental cleaning
up of the Aegean stables to go back to
the lobbying issue in this only the
family sidebar as well as mentioning
Linda Daschle I mentioned somebody
called Chet locked who it would be now
you would not be surprised to find out
is the son of Trent law
and before he became a powerful
Washington lobbyist he used to run a
pizza joint so this is and when they
asked him whether his his newfound power
has anything to do with his relationship
with his father he said no which
dramatically increased the applications
of pizza delivery boys for lobbying
positions because this is not normally a
natural career ladder right but you
you'll be amazed here you have like
aunts and nieces and the brothers and
sisters and they're all there having
access to the policymakers and to the
policymakers friends because if you are
married to a senator you don't just
lobby your husband you don't just have
pillow talk you also have access to all
his colleagues at all these democratic
or republican retreats and all those
dinners and lunches and that's how
public policy is made in this country
and if you look at our public policy you
understand why how else do you explain
for example the president's decision to
end taxation of dividends I mean even if
you think that's a good idea is it
really a high priority in the middle of
growing unemployment multiple numbers of
people without health insurance
crumbling public schools all those major
problems were facing is this really
Constitution who should be concentrating
on while at the same time the
administration is is wants to introduce
a new rule whereby welfare mothers work
for 40 not for 30 hours without increase
in child care so basically corporate
welfare is just fine but people on
welfare who are poor they really have to
be responsible they really have to work
for what they're getting and that's the
double standard that's permeating our
politics and that in the end for me is
the most disturbing problem that we have
become to nations that we have become
and upstairs and downstairs America in
1980 the average CEO may
forty-two times as much a year as the
average worker by 2000 he or she made
571 times as much and and here's the the
ultimate insult the CEOs of companies
that had gone bankrupt that were
basically driven into the ground made 70
percent more than the average CEOs so
what we've lost is this kind of
connection between performance and
reward the great American idea that even
Enron celebrating Enron would not like
what's going on right now because their
whole idea was that you did extremely
well by doing good
you know you did extremely well for
yourself and the sky was the limit but
you also did well for your company your
shareholders your country well that's
not what's going on now you do very well
here no matter what your shell heart is
your workers and your company are doing
and the severance packets these pension
plans
Jon Snow is a beneficiary of all those
things that's why it's particularly
ironic that he's going to be the
Treasury secretary there really aren't
this connected from the CEOs performance
and right now the reason why I'm
optimistic despite all that I mean you
when you read the book you will be
disgusted no question about that in fact
Larry David the creator of Seinfeld and
Curb Your Enthusiasm gave me a quote
which you would normally hear in
Washington think-tanks but here it goes
he said and I had not been as
entertained and disgusted at the same
time since my last fling with
autoeroticism so as well as laughing and
and getting mad I really want readers of
this book to be absolutely clear that
they are going to get even because
what's the point of getting mad if you
are not determined to get even and as
I'm doing him a college tour around the
publication of the book which started
last Monday at Harvard let me tell you
there are lots of young people and none
of them getting I'm letting as
middle-aged people off the hook ready to
get even and that's very exciting and
what is so promising about it is that
there is some good news about having
spineless leaders the good news that
they scare easily so if they see that
there is a public outcry they are really
pretty quick to capitulate and let me
give you some examples in praise of
making sting
let me remind you Henry Kissinger is no
longer the chairman of the truth-finding
Commission
and it wasn't because tom daschle asked
the administration
why were they appointing the basically
cover body of cover-ups to to run this
commission it wasn't because any
Democrat asked Kissinger to supply us
with his client list it was because of a
public outcry Trent Lott is no longer
the majority leader sure he's still
chairman of the Rules Committee but
that's not again because of anything the
Democrats it it's largely because of
what Robert George did thank you Robert
that was great and and also because of
what the bloggers did the bloggers and
the Internet is is who kept that issue
alive and fed with more and more
information until it was no longer
politically sustainable for the
Republicans to keep him there the same
with in an issue closer to our subject
the president you may remember again
once the public outcry about worldcom
and the corporate scandals began to die
down announced very quietly that he was
going to be reducing his proposed
increase of the SEC budget there was
again tremendous outcry he increased it
not only did he increase it but he
increased it beyond what he had
originally proposed and when there
dozens of examples in the book of how
public outcry works and the most recent
example from my work is our fuel
efficiency campaign the Detroit project
which we launched with these two rather
compelling ads two and a half weeks ago
which was prompted by a real populist
response to a column I wrote parodying
the drug war ads is really an amazing
arc of how a few people can come
together and affect public policy and
that's really for me the promise of the
future because we went within three
weeks from Bob Blatt saying three weeks
ago
that basically that's what people want
to drive this biggest guzzling and SUVs
and that that's all we're going to do to
telling the New York Times on Monday
that we can no longer fly in the face of
public opinion we will have to introduce
hybrid cars and you had the president in
the State of the Union talk about
hydrogen cars and hydrogen technology
which of course is a cop-out because
it's all about the future and what's
going to be happening 16 years from now
but the fact that he felt compelled to
do that to at least pretend that he's
doing something which is basically the
there's the mindset of this
administration was again incredibly
significant of course the answer to the
president is we can have fuel-efficient
cars that reduce our oil dependence
right now this technology has existed
since 1905 there is no excuse the only
reason we don't have it is because
Detroit has spent hundreds of millions
of dollars making sure we do not change
the status quo 37 million dollars last
year alone lobbying Congress in
Washington to defeat the fuel efficiency
bill that McCain Kerry introduced in to
maintain those totally absurd tax
credits for particularly largest juvies
and now the president wants to increase
them even further so if you are driving
a Hummer anybody here driving a Hummer
well you can actually now write off the
entire thing $100,000 because it's
they're going to stimulate the economy
right that's and that's the new
explanation for every giveaway so the
good news is that populist pressure
organizing speaking out does work and
what we need to recognize is that it's
time to give up waiting for the
politician on a white charger to save us
it's where we all want to sort of gather
around and discuss who are we going to
endorse we're going to support for the
next presidential election that's kind
of so comfortable as a discussion right
and I kind of basically stop this
discussion called
because the next year needs to be about
changing the climate of opinion in which
these candidates are going to run we
need to change the atmospherics in which
they're going to exist so they'll have
to speak about different things they'll
have to change their agendas and then we
can decide who we're going to support
but right now it's meaningless and right
now the distinctions are pretty
meaningless and the adventure of trying
to change the context in which the
presidential debate is going to be held
is really great and a lot of people are
beginning to engage in it and that's why
at the end of the book I have a whole
list of groups with which people can
connect depending on what they are
particularly interested in directly
corporate reform campaign finance reform
more directly environmental issues
whatever the issues are it's basically
about fundamental fairness and that's
the overarching theme that needs to
connect all these issues and the
American people understand that it's not
about redistributed justice it's about
fairness because right now people know
the system is rigged there is no level
playing field
in fact the book will let you know just
how many ways were being screwed and
that's the reality and really if we
don't shout out that the Emperor wears
no clothes there is no hope but more and
more people are shouting that out and
that's why I am so hopeful and I want to
end with a metaphor before we open it up
to comments and questions and this is
that no matter what politicians are
saying and doing our democracy is really
or not a pilot and my I kind of fully
recognized that when I heard a story
from a friend of mine who had taken a
trip on a boat with her ten-year-old son
and her son was desperate to actually
drive the shape so the captain let him
go up on the bridge and he got hold of
the wheel and he started moving it
around very energetically and his mother
got worried and the captain looked at
her and said don't you worry
it's on autopilot and the shape of state
is on autopilot it's been set by
corporate America so it doesn't really
matter what the president says how many
banners he stands in front that say
corporate responsibility and he doesn't
really matter that we've had a few
corporate execs do the perp walks very
very publicly in handcuffs you know
that's our political theater engineered
by John Ashcroft and Karl Rove and the
bottom line is that when it comes to
real change real restitution it has not
been done and one more example of that
is Eliot Spitzer in New York who is a
hero in the book because he caved after
the book went to press and I'm really
sorry about that but in the next edition
we're going to tell them the full story
of Eliot Spitzer who started as a hero
way ahead of Harvey Peter and everybody
else but then basically could not take
on Citigroup or any other any of the
other big guys in Wall Street and
let them all get away without a single
indictment and without anybody having to
admit wrongdoing I mean that is really
what is so fundamentally unjust that if
you go and steal $200 from a supermarket
you cannot do a plea bargain agreement
without admitting wrongdoing but if
you're Jack rabe man who has caught
red-handed defrauding the American
public by basically touting the AT&T
stock in order to get his kids to an
elite nursery school in New York sounds
like it was a Saturday Night Live sketch
right and he got away with a fine of
fifteen million dollars which sounds a
lot but not if you made twenty million
dollars a year at least and I understand
it's pizza for a column I wrote about
this so how could you let all these guys
get away without admitting wrongdoing
and he said well if they had to admit
wrongdoing some of these companies might
have gone bankrupt then my question is
so I thought the genius of capitalism
was that it was the invisible hand of
the free market determining winners and
losers not the Attorney General of New
York but you see that's again the double
standard a million and a half Americans
went bankrupt last year and I didn't
notice anybody trying to save them but
Citigroup if you want to run for
governor of New York as Eliot Spitzer
does you can't take on Citigroup so
that's really the latest example of
premature capitulation which goes on all
the time
because as I said our system is on
autopilot but we can storm and the
basement of the sheep and actually
turned the autopilot off if only we have
the carriage to do so thank you
arianna thank you very much for a very
articulate and creative exposition here
about this issue let me pose one
question it looks like you've got coffee
here dad no thank you
what I very much liked about the book
and the way you've looked at this is
that you've looked at these questions in
both parties as we know in President
Clinton's administration particularly at
the end with regard to the the pardons
that he provided there were a lot of
questions about his own family's
involvement and Hillary Clinton's
involvement at if you look back at
President Bush's time some of the people
there Josh Marshall one of the bloggers
who helped take down senator Lott wrote
about a fellow named Doug Paul who's now
our ambassador equivalent in Taiwan who
ran a non-profit in Washington with
Frank Carlucci Brent Scowcroft and Dave
mccurdy listed on their board none of
whom knew they were on his board of
directors so this there is this question
really regarding public ethics and I
think the thing that I've tried to get
at in our programming here is that I
very much believe that questions of the
national interest are absolutely
fundamental and and they they should be
pursue squarely and legitimate debate is
great but increasingly you see the kind
of corruption of that process I know
tonight you have John Kerry and John
McCain hosting a party for you and both
of them have endorsed your book written
blurbs on the back of your book but
essentially how do you expect when the
problem seems so rife with in both
parties how do you expect the sort of
campaign you're lodging to really take
take place in US in a question where
this corruption is systemic as opposed
to you know one part of the game rather
than the other my expectation is that
when we have a critical mass of people
organizing speaking out then you're
going to begin to see response from
politicians I got a call last week from
Barbara Boxer for example saying that
she's introducing a bill which I think
she introduced today to put an end to
the legislation that make
possible the kind of tax credits for
particularly large SUVs which is
basically a loophole because they're
being treated like light trucks and all
that stuff that's been going on now that
has existed since 1984 the fabula
decision to end it was made now after
the populist outcry is very significant
so in the same way when politicians
sense that there is a sort of rising
tide in favor of an issue or against an
issue they're going to get in front of
the parade again and again they'll get
in front of the parade and as more and
more dramatic changes are happening
especially the way we finance campaigns
then different kinds of people are going
to start running for office and here my
hope is that we're going to have people
who use polls very differently not in
order to decide what issues they are
going to focus on but in order to decide
how to speak about issues that they care
about how to go about and create a
different consensus around what they
believe is important because I think
that the influence of polling in our
public policy has been incredibly
destructive and one of my other populist
campaigns that I urge you to join by
going to my website ariana online.com is
called the partnership for a poll free
America so all you have to do is take a
pledge not to speak to pollsters you can
speak to them socially like if they're
any in this room that's fine but you
cannot answer their questions if they
call you in the middle of dinner
interrupt your life to ask you questions
about in Clinton's case the president
sex life or right now the budget or
whatever Iraq anything the reason for
that is that basically right now the
dirty little secret of pollsters is that
the response rate is down to about
thirty five percent as you know and if
we pursue this campaign we can actually
get it down to the single digits in
which case they'll have to recognize
that it's not really meaningful and
given how small the response rate is
basically it means that public policy is
made by a small and representative group
of bored and lonely Americans if nothing
better to do at dinner then talk to
strangers for now money
Bruce rich if I don't identify you
please identify yourself whose victim
Environmental Defense Fund
I just had two questions the first is is
that a lot of what you're saying sounds
very similar to what Ralph Nader
says publicly and I was wondering what
you what your observations are about the
reform potential of the American Green
Party or Ralph Nader or second question
is along the themes of massive corporate
welfare that needs more scrutiny in
reform
have you written about or what do you
think about the role of the u.s.
export-import bank in the u.s. overseas
Private Investment Corporation they're
currently under investigation by the
Justice Department for having supplied
billions of dollars in US government
guarantees loans and insurance to Enron
busts are often cited both by the right
and the left is a prime examples of
corporate welfare thanks Bruce I'm gonna
repeat this just for the c-span I heard
this very briefly the two questions the
second first was really dealing with
questions of corporate welfare the
export-import bank in the overseas
Private Investment Corporation which had
been targeted really by Senator McCain
and Senator Kennedy and others that were
trying to raise questions about this
some time ago and the first part of your
question dealt with the efforts to
report the Green Party or other third
parties as as Ralph Nader etc well first
of all on the question of corporate
welfare you're absolutely right I mean
these these two institutions are really
feeding the pigs at the trough regularly
and again it's amazing to come back to
the same people you know McCain and
Kerry is who keep pointing these things
out and Kennedy and then of course we
lost Paul Wellstone but just a handful
of people but this is also an area where
you can have a very interesting strange
bedfellows coalition with a Cato
Institute
that has done some of the best work
against corporate welfare and a lot of
conservatives a lot of free marketeers
who are passionately against it and I
love when you can have like you're doing
here at the foundation so regularly
strange bedfellows and in terms of the
revival of the Green Party I I would
love to see three and four and five
parties but the reality of our system is
that there is much more likely to be
social change through populist movements
then through third and fourth parties
just because that's the way the system
works and if you look through American
history many of the turning points many
of them the sort of impulses behind
social change have come from individuals
and small groups I mean with the civil
rights movement being sort of foremost
in our minds in terms of the young
people who sat down at the lunch counter
in Greensboro I mean it was in
Washington that initiated any of these
major shifts so that was the Voting
Rights Act public accommodations any of
that and with the women's movement now
we're seeing the anti-war movement which
has sprouted all across the country and
it's definitely having an impact on
public opinion it may not be having an
impact on this administration but I
don't really think anything very much
would because ultimately this present
cannot handle complexity and and the war
on terror is very complex so it's really
very comforting for him to reduce it all
to a binary threatening relationship
Iraq versus the United States that's all
very simple and they evil empire against
us you know I am a mental system you can
understand if you'll identify yourself
and speak loudly my name is Kristen
Sykes Erica's friend
the earth and I appreciate you
mentioning us in your book um I work on
Interior Department issues and looking
at some of the corporate energy
lobbyists at the Interior Department and
we've had a tough time getting this out
in the press just because there's so
much of the corporate lobbyists in
Washington already and in the agencies
and I've had a couple good stories but
the press is sometimes unwilling to go
out I know it's a great story not just
because of our camera needs I might use
this for you how do you get this
information out there because there's
already the fox guarding the hen house
and you know how do you expose the
public so they know that stuff is going
on of course they can read your book but
not everyone will know so that's the
question is what strategies do not not
to sorry Jana takers she has a book out
there and she's speaking about it but
how do people engage in this business
really take the campaign forwards mhm
well that is a very important question
because unfortunately and the media are
culprits in this and I have a whole
section in the book in which I describe
the cheerleading nature of the media
especially the financial press during
the 90s you know when we had
Businessweek putting Dennis Kozlovsky on
the cover the most aggressive CEO who is
very admiring piece or Fortune magazine
choosing Enron for years running as the
most imaginative of the most innovative
companies I mean was anybody doing any
investigating or they're just going on
on trips abroad paid by Enron so and the
larger problem of the media is that it
has a very short attention span I mean
basically suffering from death from
attention deficit disorder and also it
can only handle one big story at a time
I mean we're being we're obsessing with
Iraq and it's so much of that is so
repetitive I mean when was the when was
the last time you heard something new
about Iraq and now of course the
ultimate thing is when the cable shows
introduce special music that are on Iraq
remember it was an Iran Kosovo and now
who knows what's going on in Kosovo it's
a disaster but nobody's really paying
any attention or Elian Gonzalez you know
three covers in Time magazine Diane
Sawyer's standing on her head to get an
interview with him what
to him does anybody know does anybody
care first of all there is something
small but important that we can do as
consumers of the media and this is when
it comes to television I personally have
this absolute rule that I go cold turkey
on obsessive stories like the
disappearance of the Modesto woman
whenever I see it on I switch channels
even if the only thing going is the Golf
Channel because my point is I'm really
sorry for her but on the list of my
preoccupation she's very very low and I
don't really know if her husband had an
affair with one woman two women or three
women or ten women I don't care you know
what I don't really know what happened
in this story
and I have a list of stories like that
I'm not following and if we now have us
doubt that do that something else will
change and in terms of how we get our
message out I really think again it's
the cumulative effect of what we do
whether it's column speeches letters to
the editor and writing to members of
Congress writing to industry protesting
Street Theater I don't think there is
one Avenue it's like everything together
and said definitely a little more
coordinating would help so that we can
be more informed about what's happening
and have more of a kind of news alert
sense of what's coming up of course with
it with the Republicans controlling the
agenda so much I mean when did you all
know that Jon Snow's confirmation
hearing was coming up this week and that
it will what I did when did you know
I've known for some time okay can you
let me know next time
I knew it in fact because of Japanese
journalists who thought it was going to
be a tough a tough campaign for him I
told and they were they knew weeks in
advance that this was coming up because
they wanted to make it a story but on
this issue just if I can also add since
we're in that business here at new
America we had 15 articles in the recent
edition of the Atlantic Monthly each one
of them on domestic policy issues in an
in a publishing world consumed and
obsessed with Iraq what I find in the
NGO community with all due respect is a
lot of laziness
in some parts not laziness in terms of
organizing grassroots campaign but
laziness in terms of refining and
developing ideas that are so compelling
that an editor will run with them
because of the obvious benefit of being
the counterpoint and I think that's
something Bruce rich has been very
engaged in this he has ideas that I
think are brilliant out-of-the-box and
not part of the traditional left
community and so he's able to do things
about this but you know but McFarlane is
here but and I have talked about
Afghanistan in the back and how
difficult it is to try to get the powers
that be to focus on an agenda that
represents the national interest because
it's pulled in so many different
directions but in fact if you do if you
do deal with it realistically there are
ways ways to push forward which I think
your book helps helps propel along yes
sir right here if you'll identify
yourself - yeah my name is Nell Gant of
a visitor from Madison Wisconsin welcome
for 25 years I've been working on local
and state races including senator
Feingold
and when we work on the races where we
find to get that last 5 or 10% they're
not newspaper readers so how do you
reach them how do you get this populist
movement going when that last 5% you
need to win the race
don't feed newspapers and terribly
uninformed but they both so this
gentleman is raising the question of how
do you push that last 5 to 10% often
swing voters aren't newspaper readers
and they won't read the book but they
but they might catch it somewhere and
you've worked with Russ Feingold who
happens to be one of the four senators
who led the corporate welfare anti
corporate welfare campaign it was Russ
Feingold Fred Thompson John McCain and
Feingold McCain there was one other I
can't remember who maybe it was whoever
knows it gets a free copy of well we're
talking about two slightly different
things one is how to win elections and
the other is how to start movements and
there are two slightly different things
right I mean in terms of winning
elections unfortunately too much
emphasis has been put on swing votes and
I would like to see that emphasis
shifted to getting the unlikely voters
to vote because I'm very concerned by
the way we've given up on unlikely
voters which is half the electorate in a
presidential race and almost two-thirds
of the other of the electorate in come
in the off years so that is very
significant you even hear NGOs that do
polling that do not Paul unlikely voters
and you just think of it if you can get
5 or 10% of unlikely voters to turn up
at the polls because you've inspired
them with a message then you completely
change the dynamic of the election
instead of what happened in 2000 which
was at both gore and bush were fighting
for that 4 or 5 percent swing vote and
one of the debates they sounded almost
all so they had changed roles do you
remember you had gore
celebrating the Second Amendment and
Bush praising the rainforests so in
terms of movements though which frankly
right now much more interested in
movement building
and as they used to say in the civil
rights days you do not start a movement
you prepare for a movement the good news
about movement building is that you only
need a critical mass of people it's
never going to be the majority I don't
want to be misunderstood if I quote
landing but landing call it a strategic
minority and that's all you need a
strategic minority and that is very
helpful because we can get there I think
often that the success of these
movements the precursor to success is
picking the right rhetoric quitting the
rhetorical battle so if the president
speaks in front of banners that say
corporate responsibility he gets to
define what that means
similarly there are always pre-emptive
strikes on the notion of class warfare
suddenly try to you know don't even go
there because that's already been
discredited so what's the language of
this no movement if you're optimistic
about critical mass growing what are we
calling it can't call it class warfare
that's been discredited it's sort of
like Family Values
you know once you've established that as
you define that rhetoric you kind of
start to win the debates when you
because you've won of the rhetoric good
question just for c-span the question is
what is the new language of this sort of
populist progressive movement that
you're look you're hoping to inspire
well first of all it's not a left
movement you know we need to get away
from this again right left because why
is it left to want to hold corporate
scandals accountable why is it left to
want to make sure that shareholders
who've lost their savings and if I get
restitution you know why is it left to
care about people without health care
you know this is like the the way that
these arguments are dismissed by calling
them left-wing and certainly by using
the term that we refer to class warfare
so I think that if we really get back to
the fundamental issue of fairness you
know Americans whether they're
Republicans or Democrats frankly and
certainly whether they vote or don't
vote have a fundamental innate sense of
fairness and I get that it can
again when I'm on the road you know when
I when I give the Eli Lilly example of
the tax saving example you know people
just get it you know they get it in
their in their blood you know it's not
an intellectual getting and then you can
take it you can make the connections I
think part of what is important is
connecting the dots you know the reason
why we're allowing all this weather you
know what it's called corporate
expatriation you know it's like
basically it's tax payer expatriation
you know that there that's one of the
fancy terms they are using and the
reason we are allowing that and even I'm
not kind of enabling it by giving them
government contract is because the two
men running this administration Cheney
and Bush practiced it in themselves does
anything wrong with it Cheney when he
was head of Halliburton went from having
nine tax haven subsidiaries to having 44
from paying taxes to getting tax rebates
so that's the way you do business right
aggressively using tough accountants and
lawyers to basically screw the American
taxpayer and that's supposed to be good
it's kind of easy to convince the public
that is not good and then the question
is halting those at the top accountable
and language is very important they are
winning the language now because they I
mean even the term restatement of
earnings
it sounds so benign yet what does it
mean means you fraudulently represented
your earnings and now you're going to
tell us what the truth is sort of I mean
who do you like to be able to restate
your income tax returns you know just
risk that you're going to not be found
out and then if you are say oops let me
restate that there's a lot of questions
yessiree congratulations on your hybrid
electric car numbers I hope you succeed
I had electric car 19 said before palo
alto first guy after Earth Day and the
old effect crisis to run around one of
those things so here it is some twenty
or thirty years later we're getting
around to it I want to ask you a
question about the new political
atmospherics that you are arguing
important first of all what do you see
is the mechanisms that are really going
to bring this out you're not happy with
corporate lobbyists you're not happy
with the media you're not half use
certain think tanks and family and
friends of senators and congressmen so
what are really going to be the
mechanisms here and are we going to have
to move through maybe form of direct
democracy as opposed to intermediate or
mediating organizations to deal with
these public policy issues and secondly
what's the constituency that you're
really looking for you mentioned young
people college kids being responsive to
your message but what are the attributes
of the constituency for this new kind of
politics in photography
so for c-span the the question is really
what are the mechanics of a new
political order if you were to have your
way and secondly who are the
constituents that you're hoping to to
build into this other than the youth
yeah I think it's definitely beyond the
youth I don't think there is a
particular demographic
I think it's whoever catches the vision
and whoever is outraged enough to not
put up with it anymore
I think they're going to be everywhere
like in any movement you know they're
going to be all people and young people
the reason why I'm focusing on a college
tour is because you know as Jefferson
told us you know there is something
about being young that gives you an even
greater responsibility to affect don't
you like the musical effects that's
really good I want the microphone so in
fact you know in fact that is kind of an
interesting because one of the things
I'm doing in college is I have a
multimedia presentation that includes
music thank you and movie scenes and
humor and satire because again to go
back to your question I think we could
have to use every medium to get to the
new message and including em sitcoms
including TV series you know everything
wherever we can get that message I mean
I'll go back to you the other part of
your question but if you think of the
designated driver campaign which is a
great example of how we went from
drinking and driving being cool and
macho to being socially irresponsible it
was really used everywhere they put the
designated driver words in sitcoms
Hollywood participated so again just
look at how much has changed and with
that with smoking with a lot of cultural
shifts which is also another reason to
be optimistic about political shifts and
public policy shifts and so the other
thing you were saying was about the the
electric car and how you were there in
the 1970s
and what it is if you don't have
lobbyists and you and you and you don't
have families of congressmen engaged in
lobbying and you and you've got corrupt
think tanks what do you have instead
well you know unfortunately it does come
back unfortunately unfortunately it
comes back to people organizing together
there are a lot of public interest
groups that are doing incredible work I
think it's a matter of being
strengthened with resources with people
and just basically increasing the number
of people who are involved I'm get a
couple just a couple of questions we
have very little time left and I'll ask
you to make a single question of the
three or four you might have and make it
very brief yes ma'am very quick you know
the follow-up I was interested when you
were meeting it when you were meeting at
Harvard and you also used the phrase of
getting even if you wanted to elaborate
on that
a question getting even right here sir
yeah Bruce Merkin with the Marijuana
Policy Project I'm just curious as
somebody who's dealt with drug issues
what you feel about officials like the
drug czar John Walters using his office
to campaign against state ballot
initiatives and now refusing to even
disclose those expenditures as requested
by the Nevada Secretary of State we
participated with you at the shadow
conventions in 2000 I wondered if you
were thinking of doing a similar event
in 2004 scandal don't you think that it
constituted more of a lynching of
scapegoat more than to destroy a
reliever root cause the cause of
corruption in the case of corporate
scandals in the case of corporate scale
I'm gonna close it there I know that
there are other questions but we're just
out of time so let me okay first of all
I have trouble understanding the foreign
accent I'm not talking the question was
do you restate it but the question that
you posed was in the case of Enron and a
lot of the other corporate scandals try
a solution you suggest did it
is it is it a solution or more is it
constant form of an in my view it
constitute more in a lynching a
posteriori lynching versus aerial
solution yeah okay well let's start with
this I mean there's no public lynching
and it's these guys who basically really
defrauded the public these are not
victimless crimes and these are people
who were absolutely shameless in what
they did I mean how do you still you
call it borrow but it's effectively
stealing 3.1 billion dollars from your
shareholders as John Regas did first of
all what do you do with three billion
dollars do you buy a continent or you
know what Ken Lay did when he basically
reassured investors that that everything
was well while he was selling out and
and they were basically stuck with
stocks that became worthless and example
after example basically right now have
Americans struggling to stay afloat
because of the actions of of those men
and women at there at the head of those
corporations I think public lynching is
not the issue here holding them
accountable is the issue and in terms of
drug policy as you know that's been one
of my big issues I've been writing a lot
about it I think that the the drugs are
fighting a drug war in in is in so many
ways one of the most misguided public
policies that we have at the moment and
the fact that it was revealed that even
after September 11th we had more FBI
agents devoted to the drug war than to
the war on terror it shows just how
absurd our policy priorities are in in
terms of common cause yes you're
obviously mentioned in the book too and
we're great partners in creating the
shadow conventions and you know I would
love to see some shadow conventions in
2004 basically conventions to address
unaddressed issues that the the two main
parties are I'm sure going to leave an
address barring a miracle and but let's
see what happens I think a lot of
unpredictable things are going to happen
between now and then so we need to wait
and see remember we put those
conventions on in three and a half
months was there any others the
questions Oh getting even well that's a
great question to end on getting even
getting mad and getting even getting
even is very important because right now
there is a sense that basically this
administration and a large part of
Congress is flipping their finger at the
American people and basically saying
what are you going to do about it
that's what we're doing and what are you
going to do about it and we basically
need to turn around and say there is an
awful lot we can do about it and there
is but it starts with speaking out and
not settling for what we have thank you
before we adjourn I do want to make one
final comment I want to thank Arianna
very very much because I think this book
is very important and I'm so pleased
that people like Robert George who's a
conservative commentator equally
concerned with these issues is here and
that and there was an op-ed an editorial
in the Washington Post last week that
had kind of a throwaway silly line but
it's an editorial well worth reading
about something that may sound innocuous
that the headline was unethical Pizza
the headline dealt with the issue of the
House of Representatives weakening the
ethics laws and ethics standards to
which it subjects itself in its staff so
that lobbyists could feel free to send
Chinese food and pizza up to
hard-working staffers working on their
legislation at that night now while that
may sound small and innocuous after
having been someone who worked on the
hill and saw I don't want to knock
legislative correspondents but
legislative correspondents or LCS or at
the lowest end of the the the slavery on
the house and they deserve everything
that they can get but frequently you see
them in first class in various Airlines
flying abroad to foreign places in fully
legal
USIA approved trips to help orient them
about Foreign Affairs or something
that's what I totally support education
but there is an embedded kind of
corruption that that has always existed
even under the ethics rules that we have
now and it's absolutely outrageous that
the public would stand by and see things
weakened to it to a greater degree and
so this is bubbling beneath the surface
and I was pleased to see the post raise
this issue and that and that others look
at it because it's something that really
does cut beyond party lines or party
definition at all it's a question of
thinking about the national interest
what's in the nation's best interest and
not having that pulled one way or the
other by interests that don't deserve
that opportunity so thank you very much
for joining us today and I thank all of
you for joining us and thankfully c-span
audience Ariana has a few minutes for
those of you who want to pick up books
but I would encourage you to meet her
out in the front so she can be near the
books Arianna Huffington is a syndicated
columnist and author of several books
including the female woman and how to
overthrow the government her latest is
pigs at the trough how corporate greed
and political corruption are undermining
America the publishers website is Random
House calm